black people will be perfectly justified
and only tending to issues affecting the
black community why do you think black
superheroes only save black people
they're busy digging after time to save
the rest of the world that's the luxury
that only white superheroes have my name
is great what else is going on I'm here
[Music]
which point we detonate the explosives
and once again save the world
it's met on any questions we all always
gotta save the world
why Oh nobody help me with the problems
I'm doing it up in the hood oh it's
difficult coordinating all of our
schedules and I mean the avenging ones
focus on protecting all lives so we
should start with saving the world doing
in between time you ain't seen you
and her ain't seen Dracula cape in the
hood I seen y'all come through well you
won't go to a black box well you know if
we help the world at large that trickles
down to those smaller communities don't
answer him he's not even an avenging one
this ain't the time to be an Avenger one
that superheroes got to worry about
issues it's just short-sighted I mean
take black cougar for instance he
understands it being avenging one means
saving the world first before he works
on his own got to stop you there I am
only here to protect my parts of Africa
he said teamwork was that was a lie
white I do not care about white people's
problems unless those problems affect my
people of Rwanda
see what I'm saying stop getting black
superheroes to solve your global issues
yo ass ought to be ashamed rounding up
all these magical white folks and then
you'll bring them to the hood
that'll help all out and what was un
with dr. king
[Music]
sorry I'm late
he's returned from another time rail yes
with the stone of time we could travel
to the future and the past
muchacho yes the stone whoever you want
me in town why didn't you go back and
just stop slavery that was about states
rights Oh kiss my ass I'm going back to
Harlem I can't deal with this no more
man
night pigeon you rolling yeah I'm good
man what's most day you all stay it's
good plan dental no lame as hell man
no I can't do this man they don't kick
y'all ass all y'all you calling me yo
some lanes
well that was awkward
didn't you guys solve racism while I was
frozen
this got worse all right well let's go
kill some aliens that sounds bad
let's go defeat the bad guys
[Music]
you